he's the popular Mike Florio from the
popular website pro football talk.com
also pro football live on NBC Sports
Network that precedes us and a
contributor to football night in America
and Mike kind enough to join us now
Mike clear up what happened in Seattle
with Kaepernick yesterday well Dan
there's two different opinions on what
happened it depends on which camp you
talk to now my understanding is that a
workout had been set for roughly two
weeks for Colin Kaepernick in Seattle
the workout was due to be on Monday of
this week the 9th of April at the 11th
hour and this is the perspective that
comes from the Kaepernick side of the
equation that Kaepernick got a
communication from the Seahawks
requesting him to commit that he would
not kneel during the national anthem if
it became a member of the team he
declined to make that commitment and at
that point the workout was canceled from
the Seahawks perspective as provided to
NFL Network the explanation is they
wanted to know more about his broader
plan for all of the associated issues
including his collusion grievance it has
been going forward over the last several
months now I don't know why any of that
is relevant to whether or not Colin
Kaepernick would be an appropriate
member of the Seattle Seahawks and we
resolve this dispute between what the
two sides believe based upon whether or
not there's any objective evidence is
there are text messages there an email
message I think that's all going to come
out as this collusion grievance goes
forward it's possible it's just two
different sides
remembering differently a conversation
it's also possible there's something in
writing that's going to break the tie
either way this is now one of the issues
it has to be sorted out as they continue
through this process of questioning
witnesses and figuring out whether or
not the NFL acted with collusion with
Morda nation in keeping Colin Kaepernick
out of the league but don't you think
this strengthens his collusion case well
it can't hurt right now but here's the
thing if the 32 teams independently
decided that they didn't want to do
business with Colin Kaepernick there is
no collusion the proof of collusion is
going to be coordination and it's not
going to be something that's going to be
conducive to a smoking gun I doubt
that's going to happen Dan but I think
it's it's a matter of looking at email
messages looking at text messages
questioning Oscars coaches GM's Under
to find out the extent to which the
league office was involved in sending a
message to the teams that Colin
Kaepernick is bad for business not just
because he protested because he was the
first one he's the one who sparked this
movement and it's bad for the league to
sign him is going to be a huge negative
reaction if someone signs him we can't
lose
ticket holders we can't lose ratings
this is bad bad bad bad bad and if the
league is sending out a message like
that and no one signs him the argument
that I think that would be made is
there's collusion so if you have teams
that are buying into this notion that it
is bad for business that they're asking
these questions that these are factors
in whether or not you're going to sign a
guy and there's evidence the league was
putting out that message that it's bad
for business then I think it does make
it easier to prove that there's some
type of coordination as to why Colin
Kaepernick doesn't have a job best NFL
draft rumor oh boy
you know I don't know because there's so
much noise out there
the Patriots taking Lamar Jackson how
about that one you know what if Bill
Belichick wants Lamar Jackson the rest
of us are going to be the last ones to
know it yeah he's especially this year
with Tom Brady getting closer and closer
to retirement they need someone that
they can groom to be the successor if
there's talk about the Patriots wanting
Lamar Jackson my guess is it's a Jedi
mind trick aimed at getting the bills or
the Jets or the Dolphins to take Lamar
Jackson and be stuck with a guy that
Belichick has decided isn't going to be
all that good for the next 5-10 years
yeah the Patriots just don't leak
anything why would they leak anything
white that's what's always amazing
unless it's false information and then
Brady all of a sudden is tweeting after
Deion tweets about Lamar Jackson and I
mentioned this yesterday it feels like
there's this time frame for all of these
draft prospects where all of a sudden
were all in on this one and then we go
to this one and now it just feels like
you spin the wheel and it's Lamar
Jackson's turn this week for everybody
to say nice things about him where is
the last couple of weeks it's his mom's
representing him she's doing a
disservice he's dropping in the draft he
doesn't want to try out it you know wide
receiver it almost feels like he's the
flavor of the week
you get that thing comes yeah absolutely
and it comes and goes right we have five
top level quarterbacks in this draft and
probably the first time since 1999 that
we'll have five first-round quarterbacks
taken and and yeah we have to fill the
hours between now and the draft by
talking about something right we have to
talk about something so let's talk about
Lamar Jackson and then let's talk about
Jim Mora talking about Josh Rosen and
then let's talk about Josh Allen not
being a very accurate passer and oh
let's not forget about Baker Mayfield
and whether or not now if you saw this
when Ryan Leaf said he listens to the
interviews you know that these guys do
on the radio and he closes his eyes and
tries to figure out which guy sounds the
most like Ryan Leaf circa 1988 1998 and
he's concluded this year Baker Mayfield
is the most likely to be Ryan Leaf which
I guess is a title no one wants but
that's where we are we have to talk
about something and we have five
quarterbacks and they get the bulk of
the conversation the reality is look at
look at 1999 Donovan McNabb ended up
having a great career daunte culpepper
was good for a couple of years the other
three guys all stunk
and we never really focus on that but
there's a pretty good chance two or
three of these guys that are gonna get
drafted in 13 days and round one at
quarterback are gonna end up stinking
and the teams will have wasted their
picks and left the guy on the board like
say Quan Berkeley or Bradley Chubb and
you spend all of this time my job is not
attached to predicting what's gonna
happen for the future of my franchise
but the fact that you have people who
have studied this for months and months
and there are going to be teams GM's and
scouts who are gonna get this absolutely
positively wrong and that's the amazing
part of it and it normally comes at the
quarterbacking position we still haven't
figured out how to handicap this because
if I said hey that guy Drew Brees at
Purdue is going to be maybe the all-time
leading passer in the NFL and that guy
over there who played baseball and
college and transfer to Wisconsin you
know he could end up with a couple of
Super Bowls and be a Hall of Famer you'd
never think that but if I said that guy
Andrew Luck right there that guy is
gonna be one he'll be one of the great
quarterbacks of all time or you know
what he's not gonna throw another pass
after his fifth year in the seat in the
league like it's just crazy how we try
to handicap this and that's the great
disconnect and between all the time
and Efrain and money that is put into
the pre-draft process every team does it
every year and they pour over all of
these factors and they want to have
apples-to-apples comparisons on every
possible measurable and they look at
this and this and the private workouts
in pro day workouts in Scouting Combine
and ultimately no one knows what it
takes to be successful at the NFL level
everybody's got a ceiling from whatever
they did in college up to and including
the Pro Football Hall of Fame and we
just don't know look at the Shaun Watson
last year who would have expected him to
be as good as he was right out of the
gates you just don't know and I think
what happens because we've seen deshaun
Watson because we've seen Mitchell true
Biscay pass the smell test we saw Jared
Goff and Carson Wentz I think this year
the quarterbacks get over drafted
because every team wants their franchise
quarterback and we just don't know which
guys are going to be good and which ones
are going to be bad and one of the
biggest factors that gets overlooked the
quality of the coaching staff and the
quality of the organization the drafts
the guy what if the Browns had taken
Donovan McNabb and the Eagles had taken
Tim Couch with Andy Reid starting his
career at our head coach and everything
we've seen Andy Reid do with
quarterbacks for the last two decades
what couch have been the guy who played
10 years in Philly and when McNabb have
washed out of the NFL after two or three
years that never gets mentioned because
it's impossible to break any of that
down to something quantifiable but it's
a very real factor these guys are going
to get ruined or they're gonna thrive
based upon the coaches that are around
them for the first three or four years
of their careers I'll leave you with
this Dez Bryant's meeting with Jerry
Jones how does it go today
well the one thing that doesn't happen
is Jerry Jones says we look forward to
paying you twelve and a half million
dollars this year that's the one thing
that we know beyond that it could be a
thanks for everything we're going to
move on it could be des we're happy to
keep you but we're only going to pay you
six million dollars this year we'll rip
up the last year of your contract you
can be a free agent in 2019 but they
have to do something because his
performance isn't there whatever the
reason whether it's because that
Prescott isn't comfortable with him
whether it's because his skills have
declined we've heard all sorts of things
that the Cowboys have to do something
because the performance doesn't match
the salary or the cap number and if I'm
Dez Bryant I know he wants to stay with
the Cowboys but if I think I can still
play and I think that the offense
quarterback whatever is holding me back
I kind of welcome the opportunity to
find a team where you know if I'm in a
position for a 50/50 ball the
quarterbacks willing to give it a shot
and throw it my way to see if I'll go
get it that Prescott is far less willing
to do that than Tony Romo was have a
great weekend Mike thanks for joining us
all right Danny but that's Mike Florio
pro football talk calm and pro football
talk live with Chris Simms on the NBC
Sports Network for more Dan Patrick show
to the audience Channel 239 on DirecTV
or download the Dan Patrick show app
[Music]